بعيدا عن سخب العالم ووسطت طبيعه الساحره
الحياه في هذا المكان قد تجلب كثيرين منكم
للعيش هنا انه اقليم مارلوبورو في
نيوزلندا مجموعه واسعه من الخلجان والجزر
المتفرقه والمعزوله التي يصعب الوصول
اليها
ربما خطر ببالكم يوما ان تعيشوا برفقه من
تحبون في جزيره معزوله عن العالم تاكلون
مما تزرعونه ومما تصطادونه وتشربون من
حليب الماشيه التي تربونها مايك وانطونيا
راودهما حلم العزله فخططا للاستقرار هنا
في هذه الجزيره بصحبه اطفالهما فوقعا في
حبها
الطريق من هنا يستمر بالهبوط وصولا الى
البحر وهناك يقع اول واد ومن ثم واد ثاني
بعدها نصعد الى قمه الجزيره على التل
الحقيقه هذا اكثر بكثير من مجرد حلم قد
تحقق تمتلاك ارض تطل على البحر وقدره على
تاسيس عائله هنا قد تستمر لاجيال هو امر
غير عادي بالنسبه لي وانا مجرد عامل بسيط
فقط
اردنا العيش في مكان مثل هذا بالقرب من
البحر وتربيه اطفالنا في هذا المكان ما
الذي من الممكن ان يكون افضل للاولاد
لديهم المساحه والحيوانات وهكذا سيكبرون
في وسط الطبيعه
استقرار مايك وزوجته بالقرب من البحر لم
ياتي عن طريق الصدفه الزوجان بحث عن مكان
لبدء مغامرتهم الفريده مغامره مرتبطه
بتربيه حيوان من الرخويات من فصيله
الحلزونيات اسمه قوقع اذن البحر
هنا بعيدا عن اعين البشر يشرفون على مزرعه
تضم الالاف من صغار هذا الحلزون البحري
هذه جاهزه للشحن اعمارها ثمانيه اشهر في
الستينيات من القرن الماضي في ولايه
كاليفورنيا كنت اغوص حقا من اجل التقاط
قواقع اذان البحر وكان حلمي ان اصبح
مزارعا للؤلؤ كان شغفي حقيقيا بالنسبه لي
شيئا اشباه بممارسه عقيده دينيه
اسره مايك تبيع معظم انتاج المزرعه من هذه
القواقع لكنها تحتفظ بالبعض منها لتطوير
تجاره جديده وهي زراعه نوع خاص من قواقع
اذن البحر بسبب الوانه الفريده والمستخدم
من قبل قبائل الماور في نيوزيلندا في صنع
حليهم
هنا نرى قواقع اذن البحر عندما تكبر في
هذه المرحله نقوم بوضع لاهل صغيره في
داخلها ونتركها لمده ثلاثه سنوات لتقوم
اذن البحر بعملها وتغطي اللؤلؤ بطبقات
وهكذا تتم صناعه اللؤلؤه
هذه الاسره بدات كل شيء هنا من الصفر على
هذه الارض زرعت اشجار الفاكهه وبني المنزل
وتم شراء الماشيه رغم ان اسلوب الحياه هذا
حلم لدى الكثيرين يتمنون الوصول اليه الا
انه لا يخلو من المعوقات فهذه العائله
عليها ان تعيش حاله من الاكتفاء الذاتي
لان اقرب محل للتسوق يبعد ساعه ونصف
الساعه ابحارا بالقارب لذلك يذهبون اليه
مره واحده كل شهر ويعيشون على الصيد بقيه
الشعب
هل فكرتم يوما بمثل هذه الاستقلاليه
والعزله